Sunshine is a weather app, focusing on
the current and upcoming weather for
a selected location.
Given that focus, it is no wonder that
our main user interface is the weather
for the next seven days.
Tapping on a day brings
us to the details page,
which goes more into depth on
the forecast for that day.
On larger devices, such as tablet's,
we used a master detail view, so
you could see the forecast and
the detail side by side.
In both cases, we also provide
a settings screen where users can change
the location they want weather for,
and switch between imperial and
metric units.
Even when the user didn't
specifically open the app,
we use notifications to bring
the latest weather information to them.
All this was made possible by the key
components, such as the content provider
and sync adapter for stable and battery
efficient data loading and retrieval.